hey everybody I'm Dave and this is 20
minutes of dawn of war 3 2 V 2
multiplayer gameplay I'm the guy playing
as the orcs and I've teamed up with some
elder and our objective is to take down
the enemy shields turrets and power
generator to win the game if you enjoyed
the video make sure you like and
subscribe the first thing I did in this
game is secure the elite point strategic
outpost so I could call in my hero units
early and then build up a frontline
around it with the orcs you must build
water towers to increase the tech and
upgrade your units each one drops a
little heap of scrap the orcs and
salvaged into armor or weapons if you
have any Dawn of War questions leave in
the comment section below or tweet them
at me at irregular Dave and I'll do my
best to answer them
until then I'll shut up and let you
enjoy the gameplay
now of course you bus your elite boys
are available
why
you own email you can get them
call for more lights
[Music]
sorry old at home
you shoot the Boise's here
we bail
some enemy boys are fighting us to that
sour face
[Music]
we'll get it straight
we're making chlorine and may
we chattering shivers what we saw
who's your boss but I thank you a bath
Nick the SIS but what is it boss
our story's coming and Darwin a one-way
vartate lost
a semantical four more lights
this man is fasting
yeah all right I'll write it down way
the boys what I would over us around our
runs new boys coming up won't we sue
[Music]
can we still go party
Darwyn my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because finally come soon
[Music]
Wow
brightening up writing infantry fighting
vehicle damage
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Virgin Queen and Maine Cohen and Darwin
me
and make sure these good bus
some enemy boys are fighting us anyway
don't say the points
infantry Kimmie main for do damage
chakra
a bus
the truck reinforced upright
newsboys coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready to fight us
[Applause]
[Applause]
South Beach
in power
[Applause]
you